the chess club is expanding are you
excited for what's about to come and
what do you think the impact of that
will be on american chess well it's uh
it's got a great
great reputation worldwide now st louis
is a real chess capital
and
i'm impressed by all the infrastructure
and restaurants and
of the museum
and the general awareness of chess
around here
i'm pretty impressed
i think it's really nice because i mean
um in my opinion at least st louis the
state of the chuck club is like one of
the most prestigious events i mean it
takes really good care of its players
and i think it's a great thing that it's
expanding even bigger yeah i think it's
just it's really wonderful um the vision
um that rex and everyone that works here
has for chess um just growing growing
the game and you know the passion
and dedication that you know all the st
louis staff here have um i'm really
thankful that you know
i've been able to as a junior
of rise with the assistance of st louis
and be able to play in such a wonderful
atmosphere i think you know every time i
come here
i always really look forward to it i'm
really excited to play here i think it's
really good because i think just with
this going on it's gonna bring more
tournaments here and they're gonna be
bigger and bring more attention and i
hope boom just keeps going absolutely it
did already humongous effect on the
chest i think
professional chess in america would be
in completely different shape without
some bluish it's just basically
you know like almost the whole chess
life is concentrated right here
oh i love the the expansion of the club
it's it's amazing and it's it's
definitely very very good for for us
chess the conditions here are amazing
compared to
other parts especially compared to other
parts of the country it's really nice to
come here and have great conditions play
one game a day a rest day great prize
fund i love it
it's fabulous and also that you're in
such a prime spot great places around
it's just a place anybody wants to be
even if they don't play chess now i'm
excited to see what the uh saint louis
chess club is going to do with it
because they've already done so much of
like promoting us chess with like all
these amazing tournaments so if a bigger
space i mean who knows what they can
bring out here oh it's wonderful i think
it's great the capital of
saint louis is great capital of chess in
the united states and i play in this
club and it's probably one of the best
places to play chess
players are taken care of and it's
atmosphere it's
where it just just selects should be
always like that but it's very rarely
like that it's amazing the chess club is
beautiful the plank conditions are
fantastic and so i'm very grateful to
have this opportunity to be playing here
i think it's great for american chess
like so many of our top tournaments are
held here at the st louis chess club
so i'm really excited to see what this
expansion can do in terms of
having more events
well it's really amazing
you know it seems like i come here every
year and every year it looks different
but i just can't wait to see the
finished product when all that space is
operational
and uh so i'm i'm just really on pins
and needles like you know wanting to see
more every time i come here it's
actually pretty surprising to see like
they've conquered like another place
like another square
[Music]